salut
[Applaudissements]
à
c'est là qu'est ce que je t'aime
qu'est-ce que je suis content de te voir
mon frère on je suis très content aussi
je suis arrivé tout le monde était
gentil avec moi j'avais l'impression de
revoir une famille que j'avais pas vu
depuis longtemps mais les gens t'aiment
beaucoup ici rêve non mais c'est vrai il
est jean s'attribuer mon meilleur ami
c'est pour ça
non non pas du tout kalt sont tus et
très aimé et 35 millions de vues
[Rires]
805 millions de vues pour valider au
pape le dire si nombreux
[Applaudissements]
pour une série de canal alors on va voir
tout de suite la bande-annonce nouveaux
personnages nouvelle histoire on va
regarder la bande annonce on va en
parler juste après et mon front de jouer
juste te dire je suis fier de toi tu
sais que personne jamais vraiment eu ces
jeux à chacun de tes projets je stresse
pour toi et à chaque fois ça se passe
bien donc je des stress très vite mais
c'est vrai que tu es voilà tu es mon ami
mon frère on se dit tout je connais tout
de toi c'est vrai voilà qui attend oui
c'est vrai c'est un peu tendu ce soit
pas du tout pour pour 6 valider va
marcher plus pour tout ce que tu sais
sur moi
ça peut passer mais je suis très chose a
vraiment t'inquiète pas tu sais que je
suis un ami on parlera de toi juste
après
on va voir la bande-annonce est juste
après mon enfance je vais essayer de
faire quelque chose que je n'ai jamais
fait j'aimerais ce soir que toute la
france puisse voir validée au clair
j'aimerais vraiment que tout le monde
puisse regarder validant car ce que
c'est l'événement validé deux la preuve
le premier épisode je m'appelais gérald
brice viret patron des programmes du
groupe s'assure un patron des programmes
du groupe c'est à dire qu'à pas un truc
qui passent sur ses stars même incliné
d'un rien à glander
mais je vous dis voilà tous les maigret
et les regarde par le bila tous les
journées les fautes un atelier est le
gars je m'appelais gérald brice viret je
vais lui demander de mettre le premier
épisode en clair et de démarrer le
premier épisode des camps je donnerai
mon go away carrément we may hamm petit
problème quand même le problème c'est
vous pour la salle
[Applaudissements]
la diffusion et la bataille 1h10 je
crois mais alors en attendant qu'on
finissiez jusqu'à 21h30 et noir ils vont
se démerder
bon si vous connaissez la télé vous
seriez encore sur tf1 c'est bon mercier
pour l'instant vous êtes sur la chaîne
animaux
opan allegra tout nu dtcc allait arrêter
tout cas si l'état
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tourné pour la piété mais c'est canal+
aujourd'hui envie d'habiter sur wii
aussi bao lâm pays-bas alors émules bah
oui bah tu cumules battu fait bien merci
tu auras tu vas pas cumuler autant ici
pas non bernard tu seras toujours
bienvenu ici je peux vraiment te donner
un conseil fait pas chier car me la
fermer
non mais t'inquiète pas ils vont se
démerder cicala avait lu le sauver mais
quand même ce qu'ils vont mettre du tout
mais
il serait même pas dit oui en plus admis
au la barbe on regarde la bande annonce
ce sont vous avez été incroyablement ça
vous m'avez fait qui fait un mort
le pivot
on a eu l'idée de lancer notre label en
inde et il va s'appeler apache musique
maintenant faut comprendre faire est ce
que vous êtes déjà chaud sur des
artistes en cherche nos premières
signatures
bbc news noise meilleure qu'à majorité
des mec incroyable
tu es sur les réseaux sous qui était
repris par les plus gros contrat
français ça vaut quand ça va pas du tout
j'ai pas envie de raconter ma vie mais
c'est pas pour rien j'ai arrêté le
couple et moi sinon je vais unique et
apache musique
et j'ai besoin d'être pour ça
brême temps mais pas dans les autres
qu'on a pas besoin de ça et ouvre les
yeux on est déjà dans les enfants
japonais sont là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur canal
j'irai dans un instant juste tu as été
un petit peu en petite pression pas mon
ont franchi oui toujours la peur de
décevoir étudiés soit jamais mais en
tout cas on a travaillé pour pas
décevoir mais c'est vrai que ça a été un
tel succès que quand on prend le risque
que ce soit moins bien une saison de
quoi évidemment bon la saison 2 alors
c'est une autre histoire puisque c'est
une rappeuse maintenant c'est vrai que
question l'alfa non c'est magnifique non
le coup de maître qui l'a fait c'était
vachement aux essais quand à la fin
c'est vrai regardez avant de regarder la
ji avait
fait la bonne affaire est fait pour
qu'ils viennent chercher non mais
franchement c'était devenu insupportable
et ressaisissez vous non mais ce soir
gaulle est retourné chez évolution vidéo
gag à l'énoncé des chats qui me plaît
mais je vous le dis c'est pas possible
là on en train de tout tout tout
flinguer pourquoi choisir un peu cette
saison parce que je voulais raconter des
histoires extraordinaires c'est comme ça
qu'on fait vibrer les gens et montrer
que le rap c'est compliqué pour le port
et ouais ça l'est mais surtout au delà
de ça le parcours d'une femme dans le
rap c'est forcément hors du commun avec
des embûches
étonnant différente et ça nous donnait
de la matière pour faire une deuxième
saison palpitante quoi enfin c'est ce
qu'on va essayer de faire avec mes
auteurs en tout cas non mais ça restait
ça va être énorme je penserai thani
normes carton qui va là qu'il va
regarder acheter de plus voilà sur in
paris vous avez une partie bout oui
c'est validé ouais mais bien sûr mais je
voudrais saison à on s'en est parlé vous
juste arrêté deux maps est apte à
débuter la saison d'autres et la saison
ce dossier par bernard montiel québec
c'est drôle
la saison 2 et comme on dit il mais il
est pas nécessaire d mêlera pour adorer
valeurs sûres bien sûr j'ai adoré
l'histoire qu'on s'en fout de la musique
anti-jo tenir alors il ya des rumeurs
sur valider tu veux dire si tu valides
ou pas les rumeurs sur la série sur les
tournages franck traiterait certains de
ces acteurs de fdp juste avant de crier
action tu vas dire ou pas de fichier fdp
oui ou deux fils de pain est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vrai moi j'ai dit que
c'est vrai a expliqué que sa valeur moi
je je ne pense pas
parce que c'est vrai
oui alors il faut recontextualiser
alors ça concerne le personnage d'hakim
jamie lee il joue vraiment un fils de
[ __ ] et pour le remettre dans le
personnage quand j'étais devant le
moniteur jutzet hakim rappelle toi tu es
un fils de [ __ ] fils de [ __ ] et d'un
coup certaines oeuvres confiance
c'est un tour de force parce que voir
hakim dans le rôle d'un méchant et
passera à steam qui ailleurs il y en a
qui me suis dit je pense qu'il va
pouvoir beau diable si je crois pas non
mais magra non non c'est accepter c'est
pas du match et milices armées mais
c'est un autre à steam c'est un qui va
pas tu as moins
ça qui me boucher
ça veut dire qu'il ya une vraie
direction d'acteurs aussi formidable
vraiment acquis mais crédible dans le
rôle d'un type qui est vraiment un
[ __ ] frank aurait tourné deux fin de
la saison une au cas où canal+ refusé
que la série se termine par la mort du
héros tu valides un faux pas vrai faux
ouais bah ouais c'était un peu risqué et
puis surtout c'est avec l'argent car est
plus qu on fait cette série quand même
donc il faut leur demander leur avis
parfois et donc j'ai tourné deux fin au
cas où ils trouvent ça trop dur et trop
risqué parce que on tue notre héros ça
veut dire que potentiellement on n'était
pas forcément capable de faire d'autres
saison sans lui et finalement ils m'ont
fait confiance la scierie de france va
connaître un remake baptisé invalidée
dans laquelle on suit les aventures de
bernard montiel
[Rires]
c'est lassant bernard alors bon ça c'est
lassant bernard
canal plus souvent hésité il ya une
rumeur aussi qu'il y ait quelqu'un de
plus n'hésitez à faire valider
finalement pour sa tour notre tournée
expliqué plein de fois c'est vrai que
voilà départ ya un moment il ya eu un
moment où tu as cru que la série n'est
pas se faire ouais parce que c'est assez
nouveau pour pour canal de faire une
série comme ça et est donc j'ai
déclenché les deux armes de guerre cyril
hanouna et maxime saada et d'autres où
ça s'est fait ben on embrasse maximum et
gérald brice viret aussi qu'ils étaient
afghans sur ce dossier c'est vrai que
c'est aussi leur succès ouais c'est vrai
que franchement bravo à eux parce que la
série après 35 millions de vues c'est un
énorme carton je vais appeler tout de
suite gérald brice viret d'ailleurs un
directeur des programmes de tout le
groupe je cherche son nom puisque je
l'appelle très souvent mais pas
aujourd'hui général donc ça c'est gérald
brice viret il ya un vernis je connais
gérad vérité je l'appelle tout de suite
c'est rêver non avec l'appel des
combattants à l'appel on l'appelle on
l'appelle ce qui se passe un truc encore
et m'a dit salut mon chéri comment ça va
on est en direct à l'antenne d'un bébé
j'aimerais qu'on applaudit gérable et
giresse elle
en général on dira que mon chéri on avec
franck gastambide on a une idée pour
valider validé deuil a validé deux ce
soir sur canal tu es d'accord c'est là
c'est la deuxième saison alors là la
saison
28 mandats c'est vrai prix gratuit
patrick mon bateau lyre rapide bon je
t'explique moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
faire touche pas à mon poste
tranquillement jusqu'à 21h15 21h16
tranquille ensuite ce que j'aimerais
c'est qu'on puisse regarder validé en
clair sur canal+ c'est à dire tant au
crédit des banques ce qui doit en faire
tu vois gens vraiment comme moi quoi
voilà tu vois tu es tu démarres genre à
21h16 est ce que c'est possible alors
normalement
21h17 et à l' enlèvement à cet étage
iphone je t'en supplie les mois ce qui
pèche suppliera toujours je te jure je
te paye dès 2020 pensant que la franqui
oui franchini moi j'adorerais j'adore je
sais même pas sur la loi mais je crois
on a le droit senna le droit
de l'avant soirée je serai là des sons
technique vous voulez quoi 21h16 21h16
ben ali né en clair c'est possible je
tente y aller un mennour un épisode sur
à tous ce canal + sur canal + où lucas
c'est fait c'est très drôle s'exiler
chez lui
les égards
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
magnifique mon chéri tan amour mon
général tu pourras dire à bernard
montiel de se calmer
ça m'arrangerait également il est ce un
pas vers la montée à
tous les gens disent ça on a travaillé
avec lui les séries que je devrais plus
du tout travaillé avec lui qui sait
vraiment c'est quelqu'un de ton parle au
passé
mais bon il est temps d'en élucider sur
la chaîne olympia
oui pas tous les sons normal
mais je t'aime fort mon général
en clair il est l'inventeur fait sur
canal+